The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last
lecture on sorting.
Yay.
And it's one of the coolest
lectures on sorting,
I would say.
We're going to talk about
linear-time sorting, when it's
possible and when
it's not possible,
and this lecture sort of
follows the tried and tested
mathematical structure which is
theorem, proof, counterexample.
So we're going to start
with a theorem which
is that sorting requires n lg n
time at least in the worst case
and we're going to then prove
that in fact, you can get away
with linear time sometimes.
Both of these terms are
correct, but they're slightly
different models of computation.
Remember models of
computation from lecture two?
So we're going to talk about a
new model of computation, which
we've sort of been using
for most algorithms lately,
called the comparison model.
And it's a model of
computations that's
really useful for proving
lower bounds which
we haven't done much of yet.
We're going to prove two
very simple lower bounds.
One is that searching
requires lg n time.
This is basically binary
search is optimal.
And the other is that
sorting requires n lg n time.
This is that merge
sort is optimal.
And then we're going to break
outside of that comparison
model, work in a different
model of computation, our more
usual RAM model, and show
that in certain situations,
we can get linear time.
So that's the plan.
Let's start with this
comparison model.
So the idea in the
comparison model
is to restrict what
kind of operations
we can do to be comparisons.
It's very straightforward.
All input items are black
boxes, you could say,
in that you don't really
know what they are.
And a formal notion
of black boxes
is something we talked
about last class
at the end, abstract data type.
So it's a data
structure, if you will.
Every item that you're
given is a data structure.
You want to sort them.
And the data structure
supports a single operation
which is compared
to another one.
Only operation allowed-- I guess
I should say plural actually--
are comparisons.
I'm going to be nice and I'll
let you do less than, less than
or equal to, greater
than, whatever.
I guess there's only one other.
Well, there's two more, greater
than or equal to and equals.
So you can do all the
usual comparisons.
You get a binary
answer, yes or no,
and those the only
operations you're given.
And basically the
last four lectures
have all been about
algorithms in this model.
So merge sort, it
moves items around.
It's changing pointers to
items, but the only way
it manipulates items
or evaluates them
is to compare one
against the other.
Heaps and heaps sort
also only compare.
Binary search
trees only compare.
Everything we've been seeing
so far is about comparisons.
And so all the algorithms we've
seen so far are in this model
and we're going to prove that
they are optimal in this model.
That's the plan.
I should also define the
cost of an algorithm.
Time cost is just going to
be the number of comparisons.
This is the weird part,
I guess, of the model.
So in everything we've done so
far, we've been in, I guess,
pointer machine or
RAM, either way.
We've been showing binary
search trees or AVL trees,
you can do order lg n time,
in the regular notion of time.
But in particular they do
order lg n comparisons.
And what we're going
to show on the-- this
is only interesting from a
lower bound perspective--
we're going to show that even
if you just count comparisons,
you can do whatever other
crazy things you want.
You need lg n time to search.
You need n lg n time to sort.
So that's our goal.
So to prove that we're
going to introduce
the notion of a decision tree.
So the idea is the following: if
we know that our algorithms are
only comparing items, we
can actually sort of draw
all the possible things
that an algorithm could do,
so any comparison algorithm.
So this focusing
in on comparisons
lets us take a tree perspective
of what our algorithm does--
all possible comparisons
and their outcomes
and the resulting answer.
I think this would be
a lot clearer if we
look at an example--
binary search,
how you search a
simple algorithm.
Look at the middle
compared to the item you're
searching for go
left or go right.
And our idea-- I
didn't write it here--
is to look at a
particular value of n,
n being the size of your
problem, so binary search,
you're searching among n
items for another item.
And I'm going to keep it
simple, n equals three.
I think I'm going to go a little
wide, use the whole board.
So n equals 3 we've
got array, say
index turning at zero-- pretty
simple binary search-- look
in the middle, go
left or go right.
But I'm going to write out this
algorithm explicitly to say,
all right, first thing I do
is compare is A 1 less than x?
That's in all cases,
no matter what
the array is as long
as n equals three,
this is the first
operation you do.
The answer is either yes or no.
If the answer is no, that means
x is less than or equal to A 1,
so it's to the left.
Then we compare with A 0.
Is A 0 less than x?
Answer is either yes or no.
If the answer is no,
we're kind of done.
We know that x is over
here or it might actually
be equal to A 0.
If you want to figure
out whether it's
equal or less than, there
will be one more step.
But I'll just stop it here.
We'll say, well in this case,
x is less than or equal to A 0.
I'm going to put it in
a box, say that's done
where the circles
are the decisions.
OK?
If the answer is yes-- there's
no to this question, yes
to this question-- then you know
that x falls in between here.
Probably need a
wider box for this.
So we have A 0 is less than
x-- that was the yes to this--
and the note of this means that
x is less than or equal to A 1,
and so we basically
identified where x fits.
It's in between
those two values,
possibly equal to this one.
Again, one more comparison,
you could figure that out.
And then if x is to the right
of A 1, so this is true,
then we check x against A 2 and
the answer is either no or yes.
And in the no case-- well I've
conveniently laid things out
here, it's sequential-- in the
yes case, x is bigger than A 2
so it's outside the array.
It's to the right.
That's the answer.
Set.
Yeah.
And in the other case, it's
in between A 1 and A 2.
It's a tedious process to write
out an algorithm like this
because a binary search-- it's
not so bad-- but if you tried
to write a sorting
algorithm out like this
where the answers are
down the bottom, here's
the sorted order, and all
the comparisons you do here,
the tree will actually
be of exponential size.
So you don't actually want
to represent an algorithm
like this unless you're
just trying to analyze it.
But it's nice to think
of an algorithm this way
because you see all possible
executions all at once.
Let me talk about some
features of this tree
versus the algorithm.
So every internal
node-- actually,
I'm going to go over here.
So we have a
decision tree and we
have an algorithm that
decision tree represents.
And so when we have an internal
node in the decision tree,
that corresponds to a binary
decision in the algorithm.
In this case, we're only
looking at comparisons.
Slight technical
detail, decision trees
are a little more
general than comparisons.
Could be any binary decision
here and everything I say
will be true about any
binary decision you make.
Comparisons are the ones
we kind of care about
because all of our
algorithms are doing that.
And then a leaf in this tree
corresponds to-- it stores
or it represents that
you've found the answer.
Maybe I'll say found.
When the algorithm terminates,
returns some answer
to the problem, that's
what we write down here.
Here's where x is in this
array and, yeah, we're done.
What else do we have?
Here's some puzzles for you.
If I just wanted to look
at a single execution
of the algorithm, what does
that correspond to in the tree?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Going from the root
all the way down to the leaf.
PROFESSOR: Going from
the root down to a leaf.
This is what I normally call a
root-to-leaf path, technically
a downward root-to-leaf path.
How about the running
time of that execution?
How long does it take?
Keep going?
AUDIENCE: Lg n.
PROFESSOR: Lg n in binary
search, but in general.
AUDIENCE: The
length of that path.
PROFESSOR: The
Yeah.
Got to make sure we get n cases
right but I think it's correct,
so if here is an execution of
the algorithm, when x happens
to be between A 0 and A 1,
we do one comparison here,
a second comparison here,
and then we're done.
So the cost was two and indeed
the length of this path is two.
So it works out, no
off-by-one errors.
All right, now
exciting one for us,
what we care about all
the time in this class
is worst-case running time.
This is a feature of
the entire algorithm.
What is the worst-case running
time of a given decision tree?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The height of the
root, the height of the tree.
PROFESSOR: The height
of the root also called
the height of the tree.
Yep.
Or the depth of the
deepest leaf, whatever.
So in this case all the
leaves have the same level,
but in general we care
about the overall height.
How many levels in
this tree are there?
It's the number of levels
minus one, technically.
But the length of
longest root-to-leaf path
is the definition of height.
Here it's two.
In general we know for
binary search it's lg n,
but given an arbitrary
decision tree,
we just have to figure out
what the height of the tree
is and we'll figure out the
worst-case running time.
So this is why decision
trees are interesting.
Not because it means they're
pretty I guess, but the reason
they're going to be useful is we
have this kind of hard question
which is how much time do
you need to solve a problem?
And we're translating
it into how low can you
make your tree, which is a
problem we know a lot about.
Trees are pretty simple.
These are binary trees.
They're rooted, and so we
know lots of good things.
So let's prove
some lower bounds.
So I claim that for
searching-- maybe I
should define the problem
a little more formally--
I want to claim a
lg n lower bound.
So let's say for searching
I have n preprocessed items.
Then finding a given item among
them in the comparison model,
so all you're allowed to do are
compare items and other stuff,
but the only things you're
allowed to do with the items
is compare them.
Requires omega lg n
comparisons in the worst case.
It's kind of tedious to
write down these theorems,
but for our first
lower bounds, I
thought I'd be super explicit.
I mentioned here that the
items are preprocessed
to mean you could do whatever
you want the items ahead
of time, that's for free.
So I can sort them
in particular,
which lets me do binary search.
I could build them into an AVL
tree, could do lots of things,
but no matter what I do to find
another item takes lg n time.
Can someone tell me why?
Who doesn't have the lecture
notes right in front them,
that would make it easy.
This is a little
more interesting,
but we had all the tools
at our disposal now.
We want to show that
this at least lg n.
Why?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have a no or yes, right?
So it's--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --omega lg n tree.
PROFESSOR: OK.
At each step, we only
have a no or yes.
That's a binary tree.
So that makes you think lg n.
AUDIENCE: That's possible,
it could be lg n.
PROFESSOR: Maximum actually
could be arbitrarily large.
You could do a linear search
and the height will be m.
We care about the
minimum of course.
Why does it have to be-- why
does the height of a tree
have to be at least lg n?
There's one more
thing we need to say.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The tree has
to contain all possible--
PROFESSOR: Because the
tree has to contain
all possible--
answers, let's say.
Yeah, exactly.
I think that's worth a pillow.
See if I can do this-- oh!
Ouch.
I knew it was only
a matter of time.
Sorry.
I'll pay you later.
Damages.
At least I didn't hit
a laptop or something.
All right, so decision
tree is binary--
that was the first
thing-- and it
must have at least n
leaves, one for each answer.
At least.
Now, at the leaf you have
to know what the answer is,
but there may be many leaves
that have the same answer.
That's possible.
And indeed that will happen
not for binary search
but typical algorithm.
There's multiple paths
to get the same answer,
so there may be
more leaves than n.
And in fact, if you want to
know this kind of thing, where
x fits in this perspective,
there's n plus 1 answers.
If you want to know
is it equal or is
it strictly between two things
there's 2n plus 1 answers.
But in all cases, there's
at least n answers
and that's all I need.
In particular there's--
say x exactly matches one
of the given items--
there's n items--
so you need to have
at least n leaves.
Maybe have more, I don't care.
But it I have a binary tree
with at least n leaves,
the height has to
be at least lg n.
We're done.
The height is the
worst-case running time.
Super, super easy proof.
So easy, it's never been
taught in 006 before.
But I think it's a good warm
up for the next one which
is sorting.
Sorting is really
the same thing.
It's not going to be any harder
except that it's a little more
math but really not much more.
So now we know-- we just
proved two useful facts--
one is that binary search is
optimal in a comparison model,
the other is that binary search
trees are actually a good way
to solve a problem.
If your goal is to solve search
and all you're allowed to do
is comparisons, then
you need lg n time.
And so the search or next larger
or next smaller, predecessor,
successor, in
binary search trees
need to take at least lg n time.
No matter how you do it,
even if you don't use a tree.
So this justifies why binary
search trees are interesting,
because again the
comparison model, that's
the best you can hope to do.
So that's comforting.
That's why I like lower bounds
and theoretical computer
science in general because
you know when you're done,
at least in a given model.
Whenever-- we're
never actually done,
because we can always
change the model.
At least we understand the
limitations of comparisons.
So for sorting, we claim
a lower bound of n lg n.
You've heard n lg
n a zillion times.
You probably know this
is true, but now we
actually get to
prove that it's true.
So we just follow
the same strategy.
Decision tree is binary.
The question is how many
leaves does it have to have?
So for sorting-- I didn't
draw up an example--
I'm not going to draw
an example of sorting
because the trees get ginormous.
Right?
Because of the depth is n
log n, the height is n log n,
then there's binary
branching everywhere.
That's a lot of nodes.
Two to the n lg n is big.
More than two to
the n even, so it's
hard to draw a picture
even for n equals 3.
You can do it.
People have done it.
I don't want to.
I'm lazy.
But the internal nodes
look just the same.
You're comparing two
items, A I verses
A J. I'll just draw
the generic version.
You have A I less than
A J, question mark.
And then you'll
have a no and a yes.
So that's what a typical
comparison looks like.
Swaps don't appear
here, because we're just
looking at the comparisons.
And then when you get
down to a leaf, a leaf--
this is the interesting part--
the leaf will look like this.
Well I took the original
A 5 and that turned out
to be the smallest element.
Then-- maybe I'll
write it this way--
then I have A 7, that turned
out to be the next smallest
element, then A 1
then A 0, whatever.
Hey, right at the end, somehow
you know the sorted order
and you can just write it down.
We're not charging for this.
We're only charging
for comparisons.
So however, maybe
you've done swaps,
in the end you know
what the final order is
and so you just write it down.
And your goal is to make enough
comparisons that you figure out
what the sorted order is.
We claim the number
of comparisons
here has to be at least n lg n.
OK, why?
Because the decision tree is
binary and the number of leaves
has to be at least the
number of possible answers.
Could be more because
each answer could appear
in several leaves
and it probably will
in a typical sorting algorithm.
And how many possible
answers are there?
Batter?
AUDIENCE: n factorial.
PROFESSOR: n factorial,
number of permutations.
This is a permutation
of the input sequence
and if all the items
you're given are distinct,
there will be n factorial
permutations of them.
So that's the worst case.
So n factorial.
Now the tricky part
is the algebra.
Say, oh, well then
the height is at least
lg base 2 of n
factorial-- lg base 2
because it's a binary tree.
You can put a parentheses
here if you want,
they're not necessary.
So now I want to claim
that this is n lg n.
How do I do that?
Maybe you just know?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We can either use
Stirling's approximation
or we could write it
out as a sum [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Wow, cool.
All right, you could either
use Stirling's approximation
or write it out as a sum.
I've never done it with it sum.
Let's do that, that
sounds like fun.
So, right?
I like that because you
know Stirling's-- it's like
you've got to know Stirling
and that's kind of annoying.
What if you don't know Sterling?
But we all know the
definition of factorial.
I mean, we learned
in grade school
just because it's fun, right?
Oh, I guess we-- I mean we
did because we're geeks.
And then we know the lg of our
product is the sum of the lg's.
So this is lg n plus lg n
minus 1 plus lg 2 plus lg 1.
I think at this
point it's easier
to use summation
notation, so sum of lg i.
OK now we've got to do sum,
this is 1 to n I guess.
Now we need to know something
about lg's, so it's not
so easy.
It's easy to show-- I mean,
certainly this is at most n lg
n, but we need show that
it's at least n lg n.
That's a little trickier.
I happen to know it's true.
But I'd know it even
in the summation form
because I know that lg-- lg
looks like this basically,
and so if you're
adding up, you're
taking the area under
this curve right?
Oh, look at these integrals.
Oh, integrals.
Brings back memories.
This is discrete math class,
though, continuous stuff.
So you're adding up all
these numbers, right?
This is lg i over all the
i's and basically all of them
have the same length.
Like if you look at
the last half, that
would be one way to prove it.
Ah, it's fun, haven't done
summations in so long.
Good stuff. [? IS042 ?] material
but applied to algorithms
and in algorithms it's fun
because you could throw away
constant factors
and life is good.
We don't need exact
answers really.
You can find an exact
answer, but let's say
you look at the last half.
Those are all going
to be basically lg n.
You can prove that.
So this is going to be
at least the sum where
i equals n over 2 n of lg i.
Here I just throw away the
first out of our two terms.
And this is going to be at
least sum i equals n over 2
to n of lg n over 2.
Each of these terms is
bigger than lg n over 2
so if I just say, well,
they're all lg n over 2 that's
going to give me
something even smaller.
Now the lg n over 2,
that's just lg n minus 1.
I love this.
It's going to give
the right answer even.
So that's an equals and so
this equals n lg n minus n.
That summation I can do.
All the terms are the
same, sorry n over 2.
Not quite what I wanted.
Close enough.
Sorry there is
only n over 2 terms
here, ignoring
floors and ceilings.
So I get n lg n divided by 2.
This is omega n lg n
because this n term
is smaller than n lg n.
So this one dominates.
Doesn't matter if this one's
negative, because it's smaller.
This is omega n lg n.
We're done.
Sorting is omega n lg n.
Very easy.
Who said summations?
All right.
Why don't you come
collect a pillow,
I'm not going to throw that far.
Afterwards.
OK.
That's one way to do it.
Another way to do
it, if you happen
to know Stirling's formula
for n factorial-- n factorial
is about n over e to the n
times square root of 2 pi n.
Right?
If you do Taylor series
approximation of n factorial,
the first term, which is the
most important term for us
because as the
asymptotically dominating
term is square root of 2 pi
n times n over e to the n.
Hope I got that right.
Yeah, clearly I've
been studying.
You take lg's of that and
you do the same thing of lg
of a product is sum of
the lg's and you end up
with-- the right answer is
actually n lg n minus order n.
So I was off by a
factor of 2 here.
The linear term--
it does appear,
but it's smaller than this
and this is also omega n lg n.
If you don't care about
constants, it doesn't matter.
If you care about constants,
the constant is 1.
Kind of nice.
Easy to prove a one half.
And if you look at the lecture
notes it works through that.
But I think we've seen
enough of that lower bound.
And that's the end of
our lower bound topic.
Any questions on that?
So it's really easy.
Once you set up this framework
of comparison trees and now
it becomes just a question
of the height of a comparison
tree.
Comparison trees are binary.
Just count how many leaves
do you have to have,
take lg of that and you
get a lower bound of that.
AUDIENCE: What is meant
by n preprocessed items?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
For searching I was trying
to be careful and say, well,
if I have n preprocessed items.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It means you can
do whatever the heck you want.
So here's the model.
I give you n items.
You can do all pairwise
comparisons between those items
for free and then I
give you a new item
and then I start
charging for comparisons.
So another way to
say it is I only
charge between for comparisons
between x and the other items.
And even then you need lg n.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
case for sorting, right?
PROFESSOR: With sorting
they were not preprocessed.
Yeah, I didn't
write the theorem.
It's just sorting and given
items, no preprocessing.
AUDIENCE: What if there
were preprocessing?
PROFESSOR: If they
were preprocessed,
you'd be done in
zero comparisons.
Yeah, exactly.
This theorem is also true
if I remove preprocessed,
but in fact then
you need n time.
Unfortunately this
proof technique
will only prove a
lower bound of log n,
because even if these items
were not preprocessed, then
you have to do linear
search basically.
So if you don't know
anything about the items,
you need linear time.
But this proof will only
prove a lower bound of log n.
So this technique,
while cool and simple,
does not always give
you the right answer.
It just gives you a lower bound.
May not be the right lower
bound, may not be tight.
So searching always requires lg
n time and what's interesting
is it requires it even when
you preprocess the items.
Sorting, if you haven't
preprocessed the items,
then it takes n lg n.
Clear?
Good.
Now we get to the algorithms
part of the lecture, always
the most fun.
The moments you've
been waiting for.
Let me erase comparison trees.
Henceforth and I mean not
only this lecture, but also
the next three lectures
which are about hashing,
we will not be in
the comparison model
because for comparison
model, we're done.
We solved search, we solved
sorting, n lg n three ways.
I mean, how much more can we do?
So it's time to
bump it up a notch,
increase our model power.
We've talked about the RAM
in particular, Random Access
Machine, where
memory is in array,
you can access anything in
the array in constant time.
We're going to use that power of
the RAM to sort in linear time,
sometimes.
A more appropriate title for
this section of this lecture
would be integer sorting.
OK, so far we've been
talking about comparison
sorting where the items you're
given-- the only thing you
know about them is that you can
compare them in constant time.
But now we're going to
think about the situation
where the things that
you're sorting are integers.
That's a big assumption but it's
a practical assumption a lot
of the time.
If you're not sorting integers
you can map whatever the heck
you're sorting into integers.
And usually it's
already been done
because you're representing
it on a computer.
You've already represented your
thing is an integer of sorts.
Bad pun.
This is an assumption.
So we assume-- going to
be a little more precise.
The keys you're
sorting are integers.
There's still-- I'm going
to put a little n here,
remember there's n keys.
I'm also going to assume
that they're in some range.
And for convenience, I'm going
to assume that they're all
non-negative-- it's not hard
to deal with negative numbers,
but it's just
convenient to think
about non-negative numbers.
So if you start at zero,
there's some maximum value,
say k minus 1.
So there's k different
values they could be.
K could be anything.
It's a parameter.
We've always had
n as a parameter,
now we're going to also
have k as a parameter.
And just for completeness--
and each fits in a word.
Remember the machine
word of your RAM machine?
Words were the
things that we could
manipulate in constant time.
Now this is a very
reasonable assumption
because we've been
assuming so far
you can compare two keys
to items in constant time.
To get that for
integers, you need
to assume that your integers
are fitting in words.
We usually don't
state this assumption,
but I thought I'd throw
it in just for kicks.
So we've got a
bunch of integers,
each one fits in a word.
I could compare them,
that takes constant time,
or I could add them or subtract
them or multiply them or divide
them or do whatever
the heck I want.
It turns out you can do a
lot more than comparisons
and it turns out
this will help us.
I don't know if I want to
tell you the answer here.
For k-- not too big-- you
can sort in linear time.
Believe it or not, this
topic, integer sorting,
is still a major
area of research.
People are still trying
to solve this problem.
One conjecture is that
even in all cases,
you can sort in
linear time given
any integers that fit in words.
This is not yet solved.
Best algorithm is n
times square root lg lg
n with high probability.
So it's almost-- almost n.
It's a lot better than n lg n.
I'll just write that for fun
case you can't parse in words.
This is the best
algorithms to date.
I would conjecture you can do
linear time in all situations.
We're not going to
cover this algorithm.
That's a little beyond us.
It's in advanced algorithms
if you're interested, 6854.
But we're going to show that
for a lot of cases of interest
when k is not
ginormous, it's really
easy to sort in linear time.
All right?
And our first algorithm to
achieve this is counting sort.
Counting sort does not
make any comparisons.
It only does other stuff.
And it's going to depend on n.
It's going to depend on k.
We'll get some running times not
bad as long as k is not giant.
So as the name might
suggest, what you
do is count all the items.
So imagine I give you a bunch
of keys like 3, 5 7, 5, 5, 3, 6,
whatever.
I'd like to run
through this array
and say, ah, I see there
are two 3's and there
are three 5's and there's one 6,
and one 7, so how do I sort it?
I'd like to say, well
3 is smallest key
and there's two of them, so
I'll write two 3's, then there's
three 5's so I'll write three
5's, and then there's a 6
and then there's a 7.
That's the intuition.
Now how do I-- how I do
that with an algorithm?
Suggestions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Allocate an array
of memory, which
is my counters-- I'm
going to count each k.
I need an array of
size k because there
are k possible keys.
Convenient those two terms
start with the same letter.
And then I'll just--
whenever I see
an-- I'm going to run
through the items in order,
when I see an item, I say,
OK, well that's key 3.
I will look at index 3 of this
array, increment that counter.
Then I see 5,
increment that counter.
I see 7, I see 5, I
see 5, and by the end,
I'll know that there are three
5's and two 3's and so on.
That's how I count.
And then how do
output the items?
You want to keep going?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, just
traverse the array
of counters and the
array is already
written in order by key,
so it's really easy.
I mean I could draw this array
for you if you like at 0, 1,
2 3.
Here's the 3 position, it
ends up with the value 2.
And if I just go through, a lot
of these will have 0's in them,
just skip those.
When I find a
non-zero entry, just
write-- oh, that means there's
two 3's there, so I write 3, 3.
OK, that algorithm
would work but I'm not
going to even write it down,
not even going to dignify it,
because all it does
is sort integers.
But there's a
subtlety here which
we're going to need in a moment,
which is why I stress it,
that really we have n items.
Each of them has a key, but
it might have other stuff
too that we'd like to
bring along for the ride.
We'll see why we care
about that in a moment.
But it's also a
typical situation,
like you have a spreadsheet and
you click sort by this column.
Well every row has a
whole bunch of data
but you're only trying to
sort by one of those fields,
that one column.
And that one field
may be an integer,
but there's all this other
stuff you'd like to bring along.
And when you say, oh,
there are two 3's,
you know there's this
3, which you know maybe
has a cloud around it.
There's this 3 which maybe
has a heart around it.
That's about the limit
of my drawing abilities.
And now say, oh, there
are two 3's but which 3?
Should the cloud go first,
should the heart go first?
I mean I don't care
which goes first,
maybe-- I do, actually--
but I will in a moment.
That's another topic.
But I'd like to bring
that cloud somewhere.
I want to put the
cloud somewhere,
want to put the heart somewhere.
All right, so here's
a way to do all that.
Basically the same algorithm
but I'm just going to use lists.
Still have an array of k
things but no longer counters,
now lists.
They could be linked lists,
they could be python lists.
It won't matter for my purposes.
And then I'll say for j
and range of n-- that'd
be super pythonic here-- I
want to look at the list who's
at index a of j
and append a of j.
And then the output is going
to be an empty list initially.
And then I iterate through the
array their k values for that,
and I just say output,
extend, list i.
OK.
This is counting sort or a
version of counting sort.
In your textbook, you'll find
a different version which
does not use lists, So it's
probably more practical
because it uses no data
structures whatsoever
except three arrays.
But it runs in the
same amount of time
and this is a lot easier
I think to think about.
This is more modern
perspective, if you well.
For every item, if
you'd look at them
in the given order
of your array,
you see what it's key value is.
Maybe that's not exactly
the same as the item,
so it could be key
of x is just x.
But you know in python
sort, for example,
you're given a key function.
So you take that key value.
The key is guaranteed to
be an integer between 0
and k minus 1, so you look at
the list, that numbered list,
and you just add this
item to the list.
OK.
But the item is
not just the key,
it's everything-- whatever
that data structure is--
and then you just go through the
list and you concatenate them.
OK.
How long does this take?
How long does this step take?
N?
Nope.
Constant?
OK.
Look at all the actions.
It's order k time.
To create an empty list
takes constant time.
They're k of them.
OK?
How long does this step
take, just the append?
Constant?
Good.
Remember, append is constant
time from the Python model
or your favorite
model, anything.
We're assuming the key
takes constant time
because that's the word,
so that's an assumption,
but in the normal assumption.
So total time here is order n.
And this thing, well this
takes basically the length
of Li time.
And so when you add
it up, maybe plus 1--
because to look at an
empty list you still
need to look at it--
so you add it up
and you get order sum of all
the Li's is all the items.
And then you get plus
1 for each of them,
so you get n plus k. n
plus k is the running
time of this algorithm.
Add those up.
OK, so counting sort
is order n plus k.
So if k happens to be order
n, this is linear time.
But as soon as it's a little
bit bigger, you're in trouble.
So counting sort's
a good warm up,
but it's not ultimately
what we want.
And a much cooler algorithm
is called radix sort.
It's going to use counting
sort as the subroutine, which
is why spent all this time
on a mediocre algorithm.
And it's going to get a
much larger range of k
and it will still
be linear time.
I'll tell you the answer.
K can be polynomial in n.
So like if all your integers
are between 0 and n to the 100,
you can sort them
in n lg n time.
That's a lot bigger.
It's not just like 10 n.
I mean you could do 10 n here
as well with counting sort.
And it's not just like n lg
n, but they can go all the way
to n to the 100,
still be linear time.
So that's what we're
going to achieve.
The idea of radix
sort is simple.
It's actually kind of the
Excel spreadsheet approach.
We're going to imagine
we want to break
each integer into
a bunch of columns.
How do we do that?
Well, the way we normally
write down numbers,
except not necessarily in
decimal, in some arbitrary base
b.
So I say, oh, an
integer in base b.
Well then there's the
least significant digit
and then the next
one and the next one
and the next one, some
sequence of digits.
And if I know that the
maximum value is k,
I know that the
number of digits,
which I'm going to call--
for each number which I'm
going to call d, is just lg
base b of k plus one, whatever.
We've got to be
super precise here
because if I'm in base b then
that's what lg is, right?
So normally we
think of lg base 2
because we're writing
things in binary.
Computer scientists
normally think that way.
And fine, so now we
decomposed our integer.
I'm not going to actually
compute this base
b representation, because
it would take a long time.
I'd have to spend n times
lg k time to do that.
I don't want to do that.
OK, but just
imagine it that way.
And then the
algorithm as follows,
sort the integers, all of them,
by the least significant digit.
Sort by the next least
significant digit.
Dot, dot, dot, sort by the
most significant digit.
So there are d iterations
here, for d digits.
Sort all the integers by
the least significant,
all the integers by
the next, and so on.
It's like in your-- this is
a useful technique in Excel,
if you want to sort
by several columns--
or your favorite spreadsheet,
doesn't have to be Excel,
sorry-- you click on the least
significant column first,
and then click on all the other
columns in increasing order,
you will sort by all
of them, it turns out.
It's kind of magical
that this works.
I don't have a ton of
time for an example.
Let me first analyze
the algorithm.
We'll see if we have
time for an example.
So there are d
digits-- oh, and I'm
going to sort each of these
sorts of using counting sort.
This is I guess sort by
digit using counting sort.
So how long does it
take to sort using
counting sort in this setting?
Normally, it's n plus k.
Here it is, n plus b.
Good.
Because all of our digits
are between 0 and b minus 1.
So we're just sorting by digit.
Now here is where we're
using this idea of a key.
When we say key, I
wanted our integers.
What we do is compute
the digit we care about.
So if we're in this
step, the key function
will be compute the least
significant digit, which
is like taking it mod
b to compute the most
significant digits like dividing
by b to the power of d minus 1
or so.
OK but it's a constant.
You do one divide and one
mod, the constant number
of operations.
You can extract the
digit in constant time.
So the key function is constant
time and so this works.
We don't have to actually
write them all down,
just compute them
as we need them.
Cool I guess we could
compute them ahead of time.
It's not a big deal.
Fine.
So that's each digit.
So the total time
is just that times
d because we have d steps.
So it's n plus b times d.
Now d was that lg
thing, lg base b of n.
I have this b.
What should be b?
You gotta love the
English language.
What should I choose
b to be, or not to be?
That's the question.
Any suggestions?
I want to minimize this, right?
I want minimum running time.
So I'd like b to kind of
large to make this base large.
Sorry, this is not n, this is k.
I copied that wrong
out of excitement.
Just copying this over.
OK, I'd like b to
be large, but I
don't want it to be so
large because I don't want
it to be bigger than n so
what should I set b to be?
AUDIENCE: N.
PROFESSOR: N, good choice.
It's a good trick
whenever you have
a sum of things you
want to minimize,
usually it's when they're equal.
Occasionally it's the extreme
like when b is 0 or something.
B as 0 not a good plan.
Base 0 is pretty slow.
So if I set-- I'll
write it here--
you can prove it with a
derivative or whatever.
This is going to
be minimized when
b is-- I'll be vague-- theta n.
So then it's going to come
out to n times lg base n of k.
And lo and behold, when
k is polynomial in n,
it's k to some constant,
then that will be linear.
So let me write that.
If k equals n to the c, or
say is at most n to the c,
then this is going to
be order n times c.
So if your integers
are reasonably small,
you get a linear time
sorting algorithm.
And reasonably small means
polynomial in n, in value.
That's kind of cool.
That's radix sort.
And we're out of time.
There's an example
in the textbook
or in the notes how this works.
You could prove it by
a simple induction.